this series on netflix it has the touch
it has the power
[Music]
all right so transformers war for
cybertron trilogy chapter one is what's
on netflix right now it's chapter one
of three tribe chapters three chapters
that will make a trilogy but we just
have the first chapter right now and
that chapter is called siege it's made
up of six half hour long episodes and
yeah it's not your dad's
transformers from when he was a kid
anyway it's your dad's
transformers now or it's not not made
for kids it's
just it's a little more mature which i
enjoy i like i appreciate it's not like
there's a lot of blood
it's not like there's any blood in this
series it's not like
they curse or it's not like it has bad
language but it deals with death
betrayal you know then again the
transformers movie that came out back in
the 80s was made for kids and
transformers died in there but there's
something about
this series that it just feels a bit
grittier and
i appreciate that it is truly a
transformers for
youth and people who are in their 40s or
50s now
that grew up with transformers back in
the day anyhow war for cybertron is a
new series on netflix right now it's six
half an hour long episodes like i just
said and it's some pretty solid
transformer adventuring i'll be honest
with you it's funny because war for
cybertron
was a video game that came out some
years ago never played it i don't know
if it's based off of that or if that's
just
you know what you call transformers
adventures that are on cybertron for me
the transformers that i hold near and
dear are the original series that does
include the original movie
and beast wars i thought that was a
great step for transformers i had a good
time with that point is this adventure
is in fact
on cybertron it follows the autobots the
decepticons you know the gist they're at
war with each other
we all know that about transformers this
is what it is and this is actually early
on
in the transformers lore so one of the
things i was like hey what
what what are you doing what is
happening kind of laid it to rust one of
the autobots elita she
started back talking optimus prime in
front of the troops that's
insubordination right there but yeah
i mean they totally [ __ ] that's why
those romances never work but this is
early on in the transformers lore so
okay optimus prime isn't
you know he's not robot jesus yet also
bumblebee comes into it he's not even an
autobot he's just kind of a nomad which
i've liked about this series
shows that autobots decepticons those
are sides of a war
but not every transformer is that some
of them are just kind of
out there doing their thing so whereas
it was kind of it gave me pause and
hesitation to see this
optimus prime that was a little more
doubtful of himself i actually
did enjoy the complexity it brought to
optimus prime and i totally understood
what they were coming from with it
because
he's younger optimus prime you don't
just start out as a great leader
you get there and i was digging the
overall execution of this in terms of
visual
audio like the animation style the dug
the animation style don't know
what it's called whereas you know how it
is everything has a title everything has
a name i'm sure there is a specific
name for this animation style i just
call it the love child of cgi and cell
shading like if cgi and cell shading
had a kid it would be this animation
style in this transformers series
also the music has that pseudotron
legacy vibe going on with it i just felt
the sounds and the visuals really
complemented the world of transformers
as did the story in the characters not
only is optimus prime younger not only
is bumblebee just coming into this whole
mess
but i really dug how it showed that both
sides see themselves
as the good guys i mean it goes without
say and there's always been a little
more complexity when it comes to the
decepticon side of things at least in
the original series for me right you
take
megatron and then you have sound wave on
this side and starscream on this side
soundwave very loyal to megatron
starscream
loyal until he ever gets the opportunity
to knife megatron in the back and he's
totally gonna take it
like he kind of did in the movie i mean
the animated movie you got the touch
that one so although you see some
tension among the decepticons that was
always still
on the spectrum of ability you know it's
like well that's what they do because
they're all bad guys and
you get it bad guys do bad guy things
but with this
transformer story on the autobot side
not all of the autobots
agree with how to go about this war on
the decepticon side not all the
decepticons agree with megatron one in
particular
kind of reminded me of general leo from
final fantasy 6 where it's like
he's cool but just where the lines are
drawn he's on the decepticon side of
things so it's not just good and evil
you have
true neutral neutral good neutral evil
chaotic good chaotic neutral chaotic
evil
lawful good lawful neutral lawful evil
if they're not all represented here
more are represented than i thought
would be i took that test true neutral
it's funny because i wasn't always true
neutral but just kind of
grew to be that way i feel like there's
like a bullet point checklist of things
i just
liked in this series like i also like
the fact that the autobots are
clearly the underpowered ones they're
those little rebellion
they do not have the backing that the
decepticons have the decepticons you can
tell they just
have this grand palace where megatron
makes
speeches i don't know what their economy
is like
but they clearly have a better
stranglehold
on cybertron than the autobots have
autobots are hiding out in this little
junk
ship they're just praying that they
don't get found you know
clearly the autobots are the underdogs
so not only did i dig the fact that the
show illustrates that
every side sees themselves as the good
guys and not every soldier on any given
side necessarily agree with their leader
because they're on the same side of
their leader
but also it illustrates that it's not
just if you win
it's how you win that matters you know a
lot of us
people we get lost in the in the
possibility of winning you know it's
like oh i really want to win that
thing but how you win does matter
sometimes it's better to lose in the
sense that you can lose with your head
held high
rather than win as a scumbag i really
dug this story it's like
you remember the beginning of bumblebee
and that beginning of bumblebee is the
best transformers movie we've ever
gotten i mean best live action
transformers movie we've ever gotten
anyway i'll phrase it like that it's
like you take that
put a little cell shading on it and now
you have a three-hour movie because it's
not episodic it's not like oh half hour
adventure here half hour adventure here
half hour adventure there no it's it's
one whole story so these six episodes
come out to about a three hour movie you
have yourselves a three
hour movie that really is the flavor of
that beginning cybertron scene in
bumblebee i know
that as sure as this wheel jack's voice
in this series is
totally modeled after rocket raccoon
it's true or if this is how wheel jack
sounded
in another transformer series that came
out before guardians of the galaxy [ __ ]
i guess rocket ripped him off in any
case i dug season one or chapter one as
they're calling it i'm interested to see
where it goes after this
i hope they don't screw it up probably
because i've become increasingly worried
as to where the castlevania series is
going to go and if they stick that
landing i really hope they do
but still i'm concerned but it being a
trilogy i'd like to think that they
started this with a clear vision as to
where they're going to go
so there is that i could have gone for
chapter one i could have gone for siege
being
a little longer i i was so intrigued
i wanted it to keep going guess that's
not a bad thing leave them wanting more
right well i want more
so i'm looking forward to chapter two
all right so transformers war for
cybertron trilogy chapter one
siege have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you